citizens of the reject
Nation help I need somebody help not
just anybody
help yes we're watching the help today
Ron joy in the house let's go I can't
believe you picked up what I was putting
down you know I I've heard a beetle or
two I can't believe this movie is about
the Beatles it's going to be great you
know I've been waiting for a biop pick
of the Fab 4 for a long time oh and
finally here it is with Octavia Spencer
starring as John Lennon a perfect
casting couldn't have chosen better if I
was the casting director myself I'm
excited to watch this because I have
never seen this and everybody brings it
up I'm sure that's been happening to you
too yes it's the only people the movie
people talk to me
about well that's really good so like it
comment subscribe let us know how you
guys feel if it's your first time
watching along how what have you been
doing living under a rock like us I
really don't know if you are watching in
along uh who's your favorite Beetle just
leave it down below that's the most
important part about the entire thing
and thank you so much to preer for
helping edit these awesome videos we
appreciate you guys also if you want to
be super sexy and you want to be help
fall then you can be a patron sync up
with your own copy over there that's
where the super sexy people are and uh
if you become a patron then you are the
help I mean we like to think that we
help you you know stay entertained yeah
yeah well but you're also helping us you
know maintain this whole operation
that's because over there you and Greg
you guys do several shows exclusively
with highlights and watch alongs
included so help us help you that's
Jerry McGuire help me help you I think
so there a lot of help movies maybe this
will be the best one you ready I'm
[Music]
ready
Ah that's the title he did you know as a
girl growing up that one day you'd be a
maid yes ma'am I did and you knew that
because my mama was a maid my Grandmama
was a house slave not a very big step up
what is it feel like to raise a white
child when your own child's at home
being looked after by somebody else
excellent I'm sure it
feel I done raise 17 kids in my life
looking after white babies that's what I
do I know how to get them babies asleep
stop crying and go in a toilet bowl
before their M even get out of bed in
the morning you is kind you is smart you
is important that's what this comes from
get your affirmations in I work for the
leaf faults from 8 to 4 6 days a week oh
the wig I do all the cooking cleaning
washing ironing and grocery shopping
yeah and anything else they can figure
out for me to do I take care of baby
girl and Lord I worry she going to be
fat does this dress look
homemade do you want it to I reckon when
you finish it one well thank you Miss
Leafa still don't pick baby girl up but
once a day jeez the bir and blues got
hold of Miss Leaf fall pretty hard I hav
seen it happen plenty of times once
babies start having their own babies
postpartum depression boy come
she is did you watch uh how to get away
with murder my dad worked on that
show yeah love it and not Miser no man
and no babies Miss sker Independent
Woman So what had Emma Stone done before
this did this put her on the map in the
biggest of ways I feel like she was
already pretty well established when
this came out but I could be wrong I
mean this is at least post super bad I
feel like super bad was the real
catapult just what a different type of
movie for her yeah hi my name is eugia
feel come on eugia feling hi my name is
eugia feeling and I want to be feeling
you wo uh Old Miss Rebel Rouser editor
double major woohoo
wo this is a rejection letter oh not
exactly see uh Miss Stein thought Stein
elain Stein from Harbor Ro publishing in
New York oh Lord Oh Lord she said no
well until I gain some experience see
says right there great potential gain
some experience and please apply again I
mean could be worse Miss Mna has gone
[__] house crazy on us she Dro hairspray
or
something I want you to read her past
column then read these letters and you
answer them just like she would nobody
is going to know the damn difference you
know who Miss Mna is who doesn't know
Miss Mna Mama we're late for bridge Miss
Hill was the first of the babies to have
a baby interesting okay is that Bryce or
Jessica yes I think Bryce right Mrs wall
did you need help coming down he I'm
down Octavia did you know her before
this yes not before today before the
help I've not seen the help so I
definitely knew Octavia before I mean I
mean did Octavia Spencer come on the map
from the help as well no I think she'd
been holding it down for such a long
time before this Miss hilly moved her
into her house and fired the ma she had
had to make room for Min too see many
about the best cook in Mississippi and
Miss hilly wanted her do anything to get
her after my boy died a bit of seed was
planted inside of me it's called grief
and I just didn't feel so accepted
anymore can't cover it up hold on those
are Miss
hilles she look like the winning horse
at the Kentucky
Derby give me Lord but I'm going to have
to kill that woman
aene Miss we got so much hair here she
going blow us all up and she light a
cigarette and you know she will kitchen
seems like the place to be at this party
yeah always is this is the dynamic duo I
need sorry I'm
lying I went ahead and I picked up my
black dress from the cleaners this
morning about supper club tonight honey
steart had to
cancel again he got held up on the oil
Rick sker not the oil rig is he even
real I'm starting to think this steuart
is a figment of your imagination so just
forget it is your impression that she's
trying to set her up with steuart she
wants to have steuart
killed I got a job today at the Jackson
Journal they'd be a fool not to hire you
to SK her and her job that's the girl
from Pitch Perfect right yeah and madman
Elizabeth can I talk to aene just to
help me with some of the letters why
can't you just get Constantine to help
John Constantine Constantine in the 60s
interesting Constantine quit
us oh my gosh sker I'm so sorry anyway I
just um I don't really know how to
answer these letters I don't know how to
clean I mean as long as it doesn't
interfere with her work I see why not Le
resident hello is Elizabeth in Jess CH
yes please tell her Celia foot called
again Celia foot looking for some help
at my house you know any Maids looking
no May it's Celia foot Emerson
684 yeah that's Jessica
CH I would know those feet anywhere oh
that guy is God damn it
John is lunch time is he that guy from
fired up no he's the guy from that show
sex life sex SL life he's the husband I
don't remember his name missia foot
called a game oh I've never called her
back hly I've never called back your
lookalike I ran into her at the beauty
parlor and she had the nerve to ask if
she could help with the children's
benefit
ball what a witch how dare she thank you
aene okay so they setting up Emma
Stone's character as the only person
who's really acknowledging the help yeah
like the most human of them all she just
said thank you that's it if abene uses
the guest bath I'm sure she uses yours
too she does not oh guys tell Raley
every penny he spends on a college
bathroom he'll get back in spades when
yall sell Jesus Christ it's just plain
dangerous they carry different diseases
than we do oh my God every white home to
have a separate bathroom for the colored
Health it's been endorsed by the White
Citizens Council I bet it
has this is all good I I endorse all of
this do you think you'd be willing to
help me with those Miss Mna litters Miss
Mna get it wrong A lot of times be good
to get it right you think I could take
credit for all of your life experience I
that talking there today I'm sorry you
had to hear that yeah I'm sorry she said
it at all I'm sorry that she heard it
sorry it's happening that fre your great
sermon that reminds me so much of my ma
Constantine Spider-Man after this we're
in church Circle together have you seen
her lately no ma'am did you know that
she quit us I got home from school a
week ago my mama told me she had quit
uhoh hilly wants you to put her
initiative in the league newsletter okay
I'll be back tomorrow a
to get started on those M myle letters
y'all make it quick tomorrow's silver
polishing day yep wouldn't want that
silver to go what happens if your silver
isn't polished you're screwed yeah you
know everyone in the neighborhood's
going to laugh at you yeah you might be
embarrassed you might have to clean it
yourself I polish all my silver all the
time mhm every day in fact I should
probably leave to polish the silver what
do you polish your silver with tears of
my enemies yeah yeah me too is this a
little too young hey that's a little too
everything
that was a Janney this is
wild oh the costume design in this they
really went to town a wig on a wig mama
I want to ask you about Constantine I
told Miss won the Sugar Bowl come on you
try it on what really happened SK your
mother is sick she wants to see you in
this dress unzip me is your mother
always talking to third person your eggs
are dying would a kill you to go on the
date just show a little gumption get
them Frozen you know put them on Ice
he's iier said than done even now what
you want a giant needle jabbed into your
abdomen shoot yourself up with hormones
I got a job today writing for the
Jackson Journal she looks like 18 here
you can write my obituary oh mother what
it really be so bad if I never met a
husband skater you were just completely
against the Norms of this time are you
having unnatural thoughts about girls or
women this article says there's a cure
special rot tee
yes yes Daddy what happened to
Constantine Constantine went to live in
Chicago with her family convincing did
you fire her we were just a job tour
honey with them it's all about money now
you'll understand that once you've had
help of you home she raised me she did
not she worked here for 29 years it was
a colored thing and I put it behind me
whoa dude excuse me a moment Rebecca my
daughter's upset my cancer Solis
yes you're killing your poor poor mother
God that's true Constantine probably
spent more time with her than anybody
you think we're going to meet
Constantine or I don't know I hope so I
do
too
oh is Emma Stone has the ability to look
about 12 years old yep what you doing H
girl I could tell my mind didn't get to
the dance sure right BL we just got to
keep you out
right absolutely Bo say I'm ugly mom was
third R up in the M South Carolina P oh
you quit feeling sorry for yourself yes
Constantine every day you're not dead in
the ground bless him you going to have
to make some decisions got to ask
yourself this question am I going to
believe all them bad things them fools
there about me today no ma'am am I going
to believe all them bad things that fool
say about me today when she talks I
listen holy crap that is a captivating
actress you're going to do something big
with you come on go home with me till
the dance over come on is this going to
be like this the book that she wrote by
the end is that what we're going to be
watching here I'd like to write
something from the point of view of the
hell these Colored Women raise white
children and in 20 years those children
become the boss yeah no maid in her
right mind is ever going to tell you the
truth that's a hell of a risk to tell
take in a place like Jackson Mississippi
is it Mary steam burgon that's what I
said but GRE said no a negro maid has
already agreed to speak with you yes
ma'am I guess I can read what you come
up with the book Biz could use a little
rattet is this the experience you
require I want to interview you about
what it's like to work as a mate the
other Maids would have to keep it a
secret too all Maids uhoh well I was I
was hoping to get four or five or more
to show what it's really like in Jackson
your perspective so what y'all get paid
and the babies and bathrooms the good
and the bad how much good is there I
think it's best if you leave now oh sure
sure miss Mna thing isn't going to work
out with aene they're not going to fire
her are they I don't know maybe just
don't want her in the house or taking up
time or anything yeah well and they
probably know that she knows all their
secrets and stuff you're making it hard
of flapping your arms like that
many
Jesus never mind it's just to go to the
bathroom you go on ahead inside B it's
all right it's just a little rain oh
Jesus
Christ no she follow her that's
cruel oh
no Ry are you in there yes ma'am and
just what are you doing G
you are fir mini Jackson she didn't even
get to go to the bathroom
wow how many times did this happen hurry
aene my M's up and I'm off to the doctor
I wonder historically if that happened
that particular storm storm yeah that
they're basing it on time period wise
bet it's like an amalgamation of things
yeah hey ay no no no honey promise me
you won't go in there okay h it's
bathroom guys Everybody
Poops oh to
right oh no what's happening that Minnie
Minnie uh oh hey where you headed I got
some business attend to so y'all just
mind your own a everything okay you got
some more Miss Mur questions for me oh
no no I just wanted to talk about uh
want to talk about my book I'd really
like to interview you aene I know it's
scary no you don't yeah a book like this
has never been written before cuz
there's a reason I promise we'll be
careful it's already ain't careful MOS
sko yeah yeah you're going to have to at
least use aliases you're not knowing as
what's scaming the most scam me more
than Jim Crow that was an interesting
line here's my phone number and my car
is here I could just you watching why
people really be Downing you for giving
her a ride crazy no suspicious I think
she thinks sure no person shall require
any white female to nurse in Wards in
which negro men are
place no colored Barber Shall Serve as a
barber to white women or girls wow any
person printing publishing or
circulating written matter urging for
public acceptance of social equality
between whites is subject to
imprisonment oh my God I went to Miss
Hilly's house this afternoon she done
told every white woman in town on my
Thief said I stole a cleer oh oh but I
got her back oh did oh no what is in
that pie oh my God remember when she
said I want to kill her Lord forgive me
yeah I done something terrible awful to
that woman and now she know what I done
uhoh but I ain't going to never get no
job again oh Lord L going to kill me she
got what she deserved to in what way
what happened with the pie Leroy Jenkins
maybe she just got really really uh sick
please open your Bibles to uh
Exodus God having asked Moses to free
the Israelites Moses answered oh my Lord
I am not
eloquent I am slow of speech and slow of
tongue but not you preacher courage is
daring to do what is right in spite of
the the weakness of our flesh
oh and God tells us commands us compels
us to love amen amen amen I needed that
moment this has been like pretty
harsh going to do what's right tell the
truth I've never seen you in uniform
before look really nice thank you this
is a dress she was wearing for the
interview at the beginning
oh God clean the coaster Jesus
Christ mosquito what if you don't like
what I got to say by white people that
is a fair question it didn't matter how
I feel you going to have to change my
name my Miss Le fa every about it do you
have other Maids that are interested you
bet I
do what does it feel like to raise a
white child when your own child's at
home being looked after by somebody else
excellent so good it how' you
know is that your son yes M can we move
on to the next question you know a you
don't have to call me ma'am not here not
anywhere well she'll get in trouble
that's fair it's not fair but for the
time conscientious wow John thinks
that's fair you know she has a
boy I thought I might write my stories
down and read them to you and no
different than writing down my prayers
sure okay I write an hour sometimes two
every night oh wow my first white baby
to ever look after was named Alton
Carrington Spears it was 1925 and I just
turned
14 I dropped out of school to help Mama
with the bill Alton's Mama died of lung
disease wow 14 Alton used to always be
asking me how come I was black just eat
them up and one time I told him this cuz
I drank too much coffee
oh God he probably never had coffee was
so like
confused I can't tell you how much I
appreciate you're doing this with me
yeah she still doesn't get it though my
twin boys graduated from high school
both on the honoro we short about $75 on
one of the tuition woo I am late oh
Christ dude Jesu christe would you
consider given us a loone I'd work every
day for free till it was paid off that's
not working for free you May that's
paying off a
debt as a
Christian I'm doing you a favor yes as a
Christian of course God don't give
charity to those who are well
enable you need to come up with this
money on your
own I am doing you a favor yeah
sure Ser a white folks coffee sit it
down in front of them don't hand it to
them cuz your hands can't touch last
thing
look at me no sass
M give your mom a
kiss a every day Minnie went without a
job might have been a day Leroy took her
from my world yeah where's she going
next is she GNA go to Jessica Chastain's
house I'm wondering cuz she's got to
come back into the picture what shoe
what foot foot Plantation
oh got to be a good feeling going to a
plantation
always shooting her feet you were
cooking something one of those upside
down cakes from the magazine it ain't
working out too good come on let's get
you co Coca-Cola hey in the glass bottle
and everything well more that she
touched her after we just heard that it
can't touch oh my God maybe she's less
evil that might be why she was
ostracized from the community I'm
pregnant now going to be eating for two
that's double to cooking five other
Maids have already turned me down let me
at least get you some bus money now uh
when you hear me say I don't want to
clean this
house so you'll do
it whoa I don't know what to make of her
I work Sunday through Friday you can't
work at all on the weekends well what
time you want me here after 9:00 and you
got to leave before
4:00 what your husband say you can pay
Johnny doesn't know I'm bringing in help
and what Mr Johnny going to do when he
come home and find a colored woman woman
in his house it's not like I'd be
fibbing I just want him to think I can
do this on my own oh golly the Surgeon
General has reviewed the Home Health
sanitation initiative that I drafted and
he passed it along to Governor
Barnett sker when can we expect to see
the initiative in the newsletter I gave
it to you a month ago all eyes on me hly
I really am sorry about the newsletter
just my Mama being sick and all oh it's
fine I made you the egg and olive on R
mosquito oh thank you Henry you
remembered a better give him a good tip
oh sker Stewart's definitely coming this
time next Saturday week he's cancelled
twice before so don't you think maybe
that's a sign third time to Charm Baby
damn it sker I'm not going to let you
miss out on this just because your
mother convinced you you're not good
enough for somebody like him wow that
was the first bit of heart that she
shown like in the whole movie that was
the first thing she said at all that was
worth anything a damn yeah this movie is
really teaching me the difference
between Bryce how Bry
D J Chine also has a broader jawline
more
Ang what is this oh no a
rain she's forced with what to do with
it oh you can sell that for
$75 no don't don't do that though I'm so
scared God I just don't want anything to
happen to her
yeah somebody else get blamed it's like
they don't even know that thing's
missing
somehow what happened what happened sick
baby baby girl still got to wear diaper
when she sleep at night now don't get
change I get there in the morning at
about 10 hours she got to sleep in her
mess oh boy it Lon road if her mama
don't think that child is
pretty oh feels that I'm a stone relates
Miss Le fall should not be be having
babies write that
down yep write that down a
a
ever's whoa oh no what makes you think
color people need your help why you care
cuz that's what we're here to do we're
the saviors I want to show her
perspective so people might understand
what it's like from your side well it's
a real for that you like picnic polish
the silver and we just love not making
minimum wage or get into Social Security
yep maybe things can change what Law's
going to say you got to be nice to your
maid I have to do this now many you damn
right I don't you two give me a hard
palpitations sure I feel Minnie so hard
on this one like if I was Minnie and
that was my best friend you know she if
if something goes south yeah it's it's
not Emma Stone who's GNA get in trouble
yeah all right I'm going to do it but I
need to make sure she understand this
ain't no game we playing here oop I got
to come up with your questions too
oh I love her I love her then I get on
the Poke chop so I can get sted on that
con once Minnie got to talking about
food she like to never
Stu go for some cornbread right now we
got to get some M it hard you go try and
see okay I will go recruiting get down
here something just arrived from New
York for you oh oh oh is it the guy yeah
steuart's on the doorstep no I think
it's from uh the publisher oh get my
head out of the dating game lover of
Love Shipp ships I get it you get it
what is that shine aater all the way
from New York City oh my
God we're both wrong the whole system
cost $11 of course 11 whole dollars boy
holy [__] yep William's cousin will just
have to come pick you up himself well
I'll take the truck it's hooked up to
the motor grader I'll drive slow
don't sit like some squ Indian cross
your ankles everyone knows that's how I
always sit on this show like this let's
get as many slurs in there as we can
shall we I sit like a lady you do yes
she's a lady one drink just water please
double Old Kentucky straight the water
back you sure you don't want to just
make the whole bottle in a straw what do
you do with your time I write but right
now I'm working on a domestic
maintenance column for the Jackson
Journal you mean housekeeping Jesus I
can't think of anything worse than
reading a cleaning column my except for
maybe writing one oh my God this is
going well and that with all you girls
from Old Miss major in professional
husband hunting who is hungry I'm sorry
I'm not were you dropped on your head as
an infant or were you just born
stupid
oh you're not missing out I kind of
think he's going to be into her because
of that he likes the chase
there you
are I'm Stu a you supposed to eat in the
dining room that's how it work I'm fine
right here Minnie now I ain't messing
around no more now Mr Johnny going to
catch me here and shoot me dead right
here on this no wax flow you got to tell
him ain't he wondering how they cooking
so good you're right how many stories
have you recorded this far the ones
you've read two domestics that's all
don't send me anything else until you do
have more Ma how many more a dozen okay
and write it fast before this whole
civil rights thing blows over yes before
blows over like it has now we fixed it
all done we did it everything's good if
we don't get more we're not getting
published just write them down and
invent the ma satday y'all already
making up the name just make up the maze
too we're not going to do that that
would be wrong oh my god oh boy they
killed my son oh oh yeah there it is he
fell carrying two by fls at the Mill
truck R over him crushed his
lungs that white Foreman threw his body
on back of a truck drove to the color
Hospital dumped him there and honked a
horn Jesus Christ there was nothing they
could do so I brought my baby home he
died right in front of me oh you stop
this everything I wrote he wrote
everything he was going to die with him
yeah it's not just one story or two too
it's yeah the story of so many people
it's two people but they have thousand
stories that have weight Violet Davis is
the best actress of our time yeah buddy
you may I wanted to talk to you about
something I already know what you going
to ask mosquito yeah you do I'm trying
to get my boys off to college it's
worthwhile what y'all doing but but my
boys are worth more I understand no oh
did you also ask Miss sker if you could
borrow money of course not jeez whenever
she enters a room like a wave of ice SK
are you intentionally not putting my
initiative in the
newsletter reading this stuff Believe It
or Not There are real racists in this
town and you're one of them put my
initiative in the news letter or
what where are we going where is she
shaking I thinking she's gonna white it
out
yeah uh oh what are we doing drop off
your old what maybe your old
beliefs
what reaction don't there's a
particularly tall and very handsome man
named Stuart here for you oh Jesus sorry
for the way I act I was rude and I've
been thinking about it a lot well I
haven't she years go God damn it I told
hilly I wasn't ready to go out on any
date right was even close to
ready I'm gay I was engaged last year
she ended it I'm sure she did ouch
anyway we've been dating since we were
15 and you know how it is actually I
don't I've never really dated anyone
before ever
ever you sko I I I've never met a woman
is exactly what she's thinking well I
got plenty to say yeah I'll bet you do I
love it I knew it You Make Me Laugh
Smile to come out dinner with me for
real this time I can actually listen to
you this time I can't think of anything
worse well I understand and I'm sorry a
just give me a minute let me get my
sweater I'm not a big fan of oers
oysters are a vehicle for crackers and
ketchup oh my God they're an
aphrodesiac the boys caught me reading
your Miss mirac column on the rig the
other day yeah you read them all of them
very informative too I had no idea that
ground eggshells got grease out of cloes
I do my
homework can I get these columns she's
really just taking people's other
people's ideas isn't getting paid for it
yeah
yeah I do my homework by asking
everybody else and taking the credit
yeah skater I hope you get D something
really good something you believe it you
have no
idea oh I'm kind of into the kiss let's
go yeah you went in at the exact right
time it's a nice little Arc there and
skater she put it in the newsletter I
specifically said drop old coats at my
house not
commos
oh my god oh oh my God child are Mommy
oh my goodness no get off of that toilet
oh my
[Music]
God you is kind you is
smart you is important important why
didn't they just have her say you are
kind you are smart you are important
this is the dialect I had one Merchant
to call me and he said uh I want you to
know that I've talked to my national
office today and they want me to tell
you that we don't
need don't encourage them like that that
is national news I won't have it jeez oh
where's Constantine don't encourage them
yeah it's disgusting I mean the language
in this is
disgusting oh no what are we doing in
here oh no color people off the rest of
you let me know where you going I'll get
you close as I can oh some got shot
where you headed Wilson Wilson e cold
brutal deliberate killing in a Savage
uncivilized State sure
inhumanity murder brutality oh oh no oh
I hated that 15 minutes past midnight
ever got out of his car beside his home
in a negro residential area in a vacant
lot about 40 y away a sniper fired a
single shot a
sniper now we'll go right in front of
his chair NE we going to pray for the EV
we're going to pray for merley we living
in hail sure all kids trapped suar take
your brother and sisters and y'all go on
to bed yeah it's enough tragedy for one
day pick it up again tomorrow so they
knew the man that gra I'm trying to
think back to history with is he a
leader but they said we're going to pray
for him like if it sounded like they PR
for personally knew him but maybe not
they might have died I mean she came in
earlier saying they blew up Mega ever's
carport we going to be careful he just
do a pick up drag us back shoot me in Fr
of M we ain't doing so all right we we
just telling stories like they really
happened that is so right the presses
are heating up we needed Miss Mna 30
minutes ago chop
chop you play like a Kookie psychic on
American Horror
storying your giant Tait
repair that is funny Missy you go home
I'll see you tomorrow you mess up your
hair cing again maybe she is not
actually pregnant and maybe there is no
man I don't know you think it's possible
she might be nursing a Shiner or
something whoa whoa she lost the baby oh
no why is there so much blood oh poor
thing we got married cuz I was pregnant
oh no then I lost it a month later
Johnny wants kids now what's he going to
do with me oh Mr Johnny just going to
have to get over it he doesn't know
about the baby two before oh
jeez oh I hate to break it to
you oh
oh
damn what is she putting in the Box
whatever there was of I mean she wasn't
even showing though there was there must
have been
something you may
Davis what the hell because she took the
ring is that why she maybe how would
they
know oh
[Music]
Jee God the kids watching all this she
was a thief the day she started wow dude
and walks into a pawn shop with a ring
of such sad color oh
wow best head on over to miss abine's
house yeah
now well she got like a whole Consortium
of people
here yep oh they're fed up now yeah I
used to take a shortcut every day when I
went to work at Dr Dixon's house cut
through that farmer was a low 40 to get
there one day this farmer was waiting
for me with a gun horse said he'd shoot
me dead if I walked on this landan again
Dr Dixon went and paid that barmer
double for two of those Acres told him
he was going to start farming too but he
bought that just for me wow jolene's M
and put it in her wheel I got to work
for Miss Jolene oh miss jolene's a mean
woman Lord I tried to find another job
but in everybody's mind the French
family and Miss Jolene owned me oh my
God yeah God they willed you to her
Jesus I leave early this week for
Thanksgiving our last editor meeting is
December 17th so if you want to prayer
of this getting read I better have it by
then yes
hey Elizabeth I was in the neighborhood
thought i' Dro by everybody hide
everyone hide everyone hide thr
chocolate pie my mini made it uh
oh
[Music]
wow God they are the worst people why
did they completely ostracize her what
happened don't be taking those women any
more PES you understand
H they made me stand there like I was
the backing salesman the petty CU they
know about you getting knocked up by Mr
Johnny there you go IM you married one
of their men especially since Miss Hil
and Mr Johnny had just broke up too of
course hilly probably thinks that I was
cooling around with Johnny when they
were still going steady Mrs Walters
always said Miss Hill feel sweet on Mr
Johnny too no wonder she never put the
pieces together oh God I'm just going to
have to tell hilly I ain't no boyfriend
stealer I'll tell her Friday night at
benefit you don't need to be going to
that benefit Miss yeah Robert Kennedy
attorney general sweetheart I got to get
down to the coast
sweetheart yeah must be going steady
what if people find out what we right
and figure out nville really Jackson
figure out who who maybe we need us some
insurance what do you got in mind sorry
I need to tell y'all about the terrible
awful I done to miss
let's go it might be the only thing to
keep us safe oh no oh my
god wow I'm so curious right now this
just became a mystery movie if I take
you back I'll have to cut your pay $5 a
week take me
back what do you put in here that makes
it taste so good that good vanilla from
Mexico and something else real special
was it going to be like epicac or
something
eat my [__] oh my God her poop no
what what you say I said eat my
[__] I think you already
are have you lost your mind no ma'am but
you about to cuz you just did
oh that's like the best revenge I've
ever heard in my life
yeah yeah just won you had two
slices mama is all
right
[Music]
RAB oh my God you trying to get yourself
killed no I wouldn't planning on telling
aene I just want to see her take a bite
yes but more for what happened to PO
Miss Miss Walters Miss hilly threw her
in that nursing home just for laughing
oh my God but don't you see she going to
go to her grave convincing folks this
book ain't by Jackson now that keeps us
safe sure maybe I don't know no that's
too dangerous y'all two brought me into
this but I'm going to finish it I'm
publish damn book myself pull my parts
out all together y'all pick she is so
good too that I mean it's because the
acting is like the top quality like this
is just the best actors thank you Tom I
should be out by 10 see you then wow
this woman too they're all Stellar Miss
Walter is getting around this is Jolene
French reporting from the African
Children's B fall and I'm here with
league president miss hilly
Holbrook okay okay everybody quiet down
I got the list of the
winners here we go the moment we've all
been waiting for the highest bid in
baked goods goes to Minnie Jackson
chocolate pie oh my god
oh yeah hly
hbr no no no no I didn't get
anything someone bid in your
[Applause]
name she
congratulations oh my God oh my God I
don't know which one to shoot do you
think me and Johnny went behind your
back wait oh my don't don't call out
Minnie oh no
what are you in that up to I don't know
what you're talking about you li who did
you tell hly I got pregnant after you
and Johnny broke up oh wow hey baby
what's the
matter oh no you signed me up and I had
trouble remembering my own name oh what
country I live in but there two things I
can't seem to forget yeah that my own
daughter threw me into a nursing home
and that she ate many [__] I love her
love her love her killing it Mama well I
have one more story to Tye about
Constantine I need to talk to you about
Constantine oh you Genia it was so long
ago what happened yep the daughters of
America had just appointed me State
Regent H the daughters of America look
at
that she gotten so old and and and slow
sker oh no oh
Christ oh poor thing we were expecting
you next week I decided to come early
and surprise mama oh boy oh no oh no why
don't you go around back wait in the
kitchen oh that's messed up well I'm
just doing as I was told Miss Charlotte
going to the kitchen but I'm going to
see my mama first
yeah go on to the kitchen I'll be there
do it you may put up with this kind of
nonsense but I do not yeah cruelty of
polite Society get out of this house
Rachel you heard her go girl let me take
her to the Kitchen Charlotte this woman
does she ever get to play like nice
people this woman I feel like she gets
typ cast a lot of like overbearing Stern
characters I'm so sad right now
yeah this is
cruel Constantine didn't do anything
wrong of course not did you think she
did yeah like shocking what gives you
cause to believe anyone standards that
high you idolized her too much you
always have I needed someone to look up
to yeah I went to her house the next day
but she had already gone yeah this is
probably the only thing keeping her here
a little one do that means sker had gone
to her house a lot too guess so I'm she
needs me Eugenia what we sent your
brother up to Chicago to bring
Constantine home she died yeah when he
got there she died I knew it it's like
so you do have a soul you just buried it
buried it and did the wrong thing yeah
[Music]
hey by Anonymous that was fast they
printed a few thousand copies with the
worst Advance Miss Stein had ever seen
they sent M SK
$600 she broke that money up and gave it
to each of us a we just got this
mosquito look at
[Music]
it fired me for using her inside toilet
put me out in a storm and told me never
to come back but I did come back hey I
came back with a pie I had baked to say
I'm sorry I watched her
eat this is the first time she realizes
about her daughter oh um you should read
the book hly it's quite scandalous
Jesus Oh everyone's got a copy now told
me to WR something good something I
believed in it's not what I believe in
oh [__] trouble's already here steuart I
had to tell you this you needed to know
God damn right I needed to know you
should have told me this from the start
you're a selfish woman sker yes yes of
course that was very selfish of her I
think you're better off being alone okay
forever goodbye then it's so hard once
you're in love with somebody because at
the beginning if you had said this she
would just have piss off yeah you know
just ask every potential Suitor if
they're raging racist and then move on I
honestly ly for a while on the dating
apps I used to ask people where were you
on January
6th I was at our nation's capital as a
matter of fact just
[Music]
checking music in this movie is great oh
that story hit home didn't it which one
you think of Constantine that's yeah
that's
hers yep oh no oh no no yes where is
this going to go what's
oh my God I heard that Betty character
might be Mary Elizabeth it's not Jackson
and that book is garbage I bet the whole
thing is made up by some
[__] a fat
check two slice
hilly that's his Jesus
Christ you Ain going to take that 200
wow oh Harper and row not bad now you
got experience oh Missy you're going to
jail you can't prove anything aene ought
to have been a little bit smarter before
putting in about that L-shaped scratch
in poor Elizabeth's d in table yes and
that your mini do I have plans for her
careful hilly that's chapter
12 that was not me I mother what hippie
you've become yes everything okay you
two Mrs really you very gray Gardens
right now you're sweaty mess are you ill
you look like [__] you know hilly if I
didn't know any better I'd say you've
been eating too much pie oh
oh you get your raggedy ass off my
porch see we knew she had a soul even
though she you can't make up for what
you did but you can move forward as a
better person we are going shopping no
single daughter of mine is going to New
York City representing the great state
of Mississippi without a proper
Cosmopolitan wardrobe o courage
sometimes Skips a generation yeah thank
you for bringing it back to our family
yep well done and I know the doctor says
it's some kind of last strank nonsense
but I have decided not to die good for
you same I have never been more proud of
you there we go well done what every kid
wants their mom to say when when you
know you're doing the right
thing oh
no nice ride though oh no oh no oh no
Miss hey
stopnie
minute I'm not here to hurt you girl Z
you finally told me about the babies but
I also know that the minute you started
working here she started getting better
yeah you knew I was here the whole time
fried chicken and okra on the first
night I mean y'all could have at least
put some corn pone on the table I could
let you eat no more corn pone Mr Johnny
but thanks to you now I've had to let
out every pair of pants I own make me
some new pants so the foots who live on
an actual plant
are some of the least shitty white
people in this part of
Mississippi interesting irony I cooked
it all by myself yes she did she was up
all night wanted to do something special
oh man's like I don't want your cooking
bab I ain't losing my job you got a job
here for the rest of your life if you
want it yeah okay
a please
a look at common d see yeah but here you
and I are like they're such good people
bare middle no all of us white folks are
better for this moment we all did our
part just by watching this movie yeah
that's it don't have to do anything else
done woke racism is fixed my white guilt
is
assuaged what are all these cars doing
out here we late no we a late I also
have questions on how people got the
commodes to the lawn yep
yep you just holding on to this old
toilet or did you rip it out to bring it
here so many of
them let's just love the word kode oh
CLA clapping for you CL for you
yep on down
s come on who is the preacher he looks
really familiar yeah he does look really
familiar I was thinking about that it's
so hard cuz this movie was how many
years ago 10 probably it's like probably
we've seen him in things since then but
maybe it looks different now yeah this
is an important time in our community
and we have to thank you what you have
done we know you couldn't put your name
in here so we all signed our a still got
white jesus on that fan
[Laughter]
though was he in Selma maybe maybe W
over two County sign up I it all for you
and me I haven't seen it either that's
next that's next I got a job offer from
harburn Row in New York can't just leave
you two here things are getting bad from
the mess that I created bad things
happen ain't nothing you can do about it
yeah you ain't got a good life here in
Jackson plus your mama is getting better
you ain't got nothing left here but
enemies in the
Gen go find your life M
sko the silver I lent Elizabeth last
week and I polish good humidity and been
fighting me on polishing day when you
you returned it three pieces were
missing from the felt wrapper oh no and
two spoons let me go check in the
kitchen maybe I left some behind you
know as well as I do that silver is not
in the kitchen what she's going to get
her
arrested since little man was born she'
been putting things in it do you hear
her Elizabeth oh you hit him yourself
then it behooves me to inform you that
you are fired aene kid's going to come
barf up a bunch of spoons I Ste no
silver maybe I can't send you to jail
for what you wrote but I can send you
for being a thief I know something about
you don't you forget man yep but what
you may says there a lot of time to
write letters in jail plenty of time to
write the truth about you yeah nobody
would believe what you wrot I don't know
I've been told I'm a pretty good writer
already sold a lot of books no damn call
the police there
b you do is SC and lie to try to get
what you want aene stop you a Godless
woman yes you are you have to go now
don't go
baby yeah I don't want to leave you but
it's time for me to retire you're my
last little girl no you remember what I
told
you is
[Music]
smart that's right baby girl here here
you give my sweet girl a
chance yeah be an actual mom maybe May
Mo was my last baby in just 10 minutes
the only life I knew was
[Music]
done
oh God says we need to love our enemies
they're hard to do cruel thing for God
to say yeah no one had ever asked me
what it feel like to be me God such a
simple question too once I told the
truth about that I felt free my boy trew
always said we going to have a riter in
the family one
day I guess it's going to be me yes
ma'am you should head to New York is she
gonna do ghost right fromma Stone
yeah
wowe it's like my mind is going a
million miles an hour because I'm just
like how is she gonna make money now how
is she going to survive yeah how is she
going to live written for the screen and
directed by Tate Taylor
based on a novel okay Catherine
stocket
interesting Chris
Columbus told you you did
yeah
interesting what's crazy about these
ending shots like this is like you know
that Violet had to walk for so long just
to get the shot she's like is it cut yet
they're like just keep going babe keep
going just keep keep going don't stop we
need you for minutes keep it
pushing
damn it's like a silent movie he's just
off screen okay little little faster no
too F okay slow down all right are we
gonna at what point are we gonna cut so
but this wasn't based on real characters
in terms of the novel you don't think
that cuz I was kind of expecting at the
end to see to see real people
like that yeah kind of like yeah I would
be very curious as to the historical
context I mean I'm sure this is I would
imagine this is based off of real
experiences and amalgamations of real
people well of course we were seeing
real historical events but I just don't
know whether that like was there an Emma
Stone character was there Violet Davis
yeah or is it it's said based on the
novel so I'm like yeah is this
what degree of fiction are we coming out
of
yeah she's still walking
yeah keep it going keep it
pushing the music was really excellent
in this yeah yeah it really was I mean
okay oh it was [__] [__] that's right
that's the mom that's what her name is
what is your initial thoughts on this I
mean I enjoyed it for sure it's it's
steon there you go it's very heartfelt
it's one of those things where I think I
think the obvious kind of elephant in
the room is that I I believe this is a
film authored by white folks or at least
in the writing directing that side of
things
so part of me you know is sitting here
going like well I can only imagine what
this story As Told by black folks might
be like in terms of you know the real
lived in perspective there is some of
that stuff where like yeah at the end
it's like she goes off to New York and
has a job as a writer and you know um
abelen loses her job and I don't know
really what this means it has an
optimistic note at the end but you know
she's she's been fired and she's just
kind of walking off into opportunity but
I don't really know what that means and
I don't know if she's a real person to
think that okay so she goes on to some
other thing like is she actually walking
into opportunity like what is yeah or I
mean cuz the thing is
yeah it's one of those things where this
is a story about you know a white
character taking interest in and and
doing the bare minimum of seeing you
know these various
African-Americans in these you know
service positions as people doing the
bare minimum of seeing them as people
and treating them with respect but then
also I understand why people believe
that it's problematic because not only
doing the bare minimum seeing them but
then using them to advance herself
yeah you know I don't think that was the
purpose of her writing the book but that
was the outcome of her writing the book
is that she gets to take their words and
their stories and she gets to use that
to live her dream and move to New York
yeah it's a dual thing it's like she
writes about something she believes in
and they draw the character as somebody
who genuinely yeah like cares about this
and wants to do it
for decent reasons but but it is two
birds with one stone it's like and now
she's going to go off and have this big
opportunity in New York leave
Mississippi behind where this
publication is probably going to cause
trouble for a lot of people and people
are probably going to have to deal with
very real very harsh circumstances
because of this and it's one of those
things where you're like you know you
need the progress again it's like I
don't know I'm let's find out like I
don't know how to discuss this
ultimately because I don't know how true
it is yeah I know what you mean though
because it's like in the in your soul if
you're Illuminating a
problem 201 11 it said okay if you're
Illuminating if you're shining a light
on something that's taking place then
you are doing something positive but but
then you're using it to okay what tell T
Taylor and Katherine stocket are white
folks okay um let's see the novel who
are the them they they the writers of
the novel uh Tate Taylor wrote and
directed the movie and Katherine stocket
uh wrote the book okay
um let's see
and you're right now we're tring okay so
I I
guess oh interesting okay tell me what
abene uh aene Cooper a housekeeper who
once work for stockett's brother
criticized the author for stealing her
life story without her knowledge and
basing the character on of abene uh on
her likeness uh sued stocket for 75,000
in
Damages um wow yeah I don't know I mean
I guess so her brother Katherine
stockett's
brother yeah knew
aene or at least a person who yeah
became the spelling of of the name here
is a bit different abene uh but yeah I
mean ostensibly the character who would
be abene is somebody that she knew it it
is so it's it's hard because I think
that that was a very well-made movie and
also like it did a clear job of showing
people who are you're either on the
right side of history or you're not
right like and then there's varying
degrees of that it's not black and white
it's black white and everywhere in
between of course um I'm talking about
like your your your ideology it is black
and white but it's not yeah yeah yeah
it's very great I think that but it is
interesting because when we talk about
movies of course watching it I was like
wow this is really well done the
performances are great I love the music
it just seems like a big scope you know
like the sets were incredible the
costume design was amazing the hair and
makeup was wonderful like it just even
the yeah the sound design we were
talking the food like all the elements
and the story is interesting and it
pulls at your heartstrings and yet
there's also that other element which is
like uh this like we're still continuing
to monopolize on people's pain without
them receiving that Finance you know
like yeah they're not going to earn
residuals off this book like it's good
of her to take that 600 and split it up
against all the people who are you know
between all the people who contributed
their stories but at the same time
you're going to reap the large scale
benefits of this whereas they're going
to get that onetime payment and like
again it contributes obviously in the
movies Universe to oh everyone's reading
the book and people are getting a better
idea of what really happens in behind
other people's closed doors you know is
you're bringing the secrets out we all
pretend one way and there is I mean the
movie deals so much with like the
toxicity and the poison the Venom of
polite Society basically uh the
bold-faced kind of
horrific I don't know just yeah
um I don't know what the word is but
yeah just the way people in like right
in front of uh their Maids or whoever it
might be are saying these awful things
and then immediately turning back to you
know like oh we're playing bridge or oh
we're at some kind of charity event and
oh the decorum yeah that was actually
one of my favorite moments in the whole
movie because it it made the movie a
little more self-aware when Bryce Dallas
Howard's character is like talking to uh
Emma Stone's character and is like your
mom can't convince you you're not pretty
enough to be with somebody you know
because I think when we think of people
who are evil or people who are not on
the right side of things we think
moahaha like if you were in a room with
them for 30 seconds you would know they
were a bad person but the truth is most
people who are racist most people who
are homophobic most people who are
sexist most people who are have extreme
prejudice in their heart also have love
for their friends and their family and
also like say kind things to people
sometimes and so I think that it does
get it's not confusing when you're
watching it but when you meet people in
life and you're like but they're nice to
me how could they possibly evil to the
rest of the world you know and I think
that they did a good job showing that
here where like while Bryce Dallas
Howard maybe at first was being a good
friend to her friends that doesn't make
her a decent human she's an inent human
all yeah I mean she's she is the kind of
quintessential you know uh uh you know
hoyy toyy High Society like you know
she's the person you know she's leading
this uh what is it she's got this
initiative she's trying to lead and
she's trying to do like the African
children's starvation fund and stuff
like that you know really posing as a
pillar of society while also being
wretched as a human being and and and
being inhumane to so many other people
you know in in in the process of that
right like you won't give somebody $75
in an advance and yet you'll throw a
Galla for children in Africa It's like
because it's all for yeah it's all for
you it's all it's all for her it's all
for her status it's all for her errors
that she's putting on in in again polite
Society it's all about the image it's
all about the facade and yeah it I think
that was a great moment where she asked
at the end aren't you tired like aren't
you tired of of creating this you know
illusion of yourself that is clearly not
who you are and is corroding your soul
trying to maintain you know just like at
at a certain point I've heard people say
you know it's just like don't even try
to cover just be who you are you know
like if you're that ugly on the inside
just be that person and then we know
yeah totally you it's better that than a
a wolf and sheep's clothing which is
what we see all the time I also really
appreciated Alison jany's character in
here because I do think that change is
important and if we don't allow people
to change and grow then what's the point
in having any kind of content that shows
the that opens your eyes to anything
right so like she doesn't get credit for
starting to be a better person but
anybody can wake up any day of their
life and decide to do the right thing
yeah even if you've done the wrong thing
80,000 times the Constantine the
Constantine storyline really really like
affected me I thought that that was
devastating I mean yeah was they dided
and a good job with that one did you
have a character that you I don't know
if the right terminology is like liked
best or one that like you feel felt the
most for or just were like when they
were on screen you were the most
captivated by probably Minnie or abene I
mean those two in their own unique ways
just had I mean octavus Spencer and uh
and um via Davis are just such great
actors and they really brought so much
life and presence to those characters
and and the stories and whatnot I mean I
you know this is it's an interesting
movie to process now in a post greenbook
world uh because because yeah like on
the one hand I feel like it does at
least do a fair job and and again I
don't have the perspective to know you
know like I haven't grown up with this
history in my family or anything like
that to be aware or not like I don't
have the black folks perspective you
know so I'm sure that there are probably
ways in which the accounts may be
distorted uh and the representations of
what life was actually like may be
distorted here um but I don't know I
thought they brought those characters to
life really vitally
and I really appreciated both the the
you know obviously there's a depth of
sorrow and pain with those characters
because of the position that they're in
because of the way people speak to and
about them and the way they're regarded
you know just the way this mindset that
is so there there's that one speech
happening on the TV at one point where
they're like Mississippi is like at the
lowest of the low in terms of like you
know any kind of Humane treatment of our
people and and so you know that uh I
don't know it is a movie that does have
a heartfelt to it and I think its heart
feels like it's in the right place uh it
is I don't know it's it's a problematic
one but it's like wellmade you know what
I mean like yeah part of me does feel
like like does it do more harm than good
or good than
harm I guess it it it probably helps I'm
going to go out on a limb and say and I
don't want to be presumptuous obviously
um but you know I
guess net positive for like a white
audience who needs to see this kind of
thing you know like it's that it's like
I like I've seen green book I didn't
hate green book you watch it and you're
like yeah this is enjoyable this there
are good performances there good
production values it's heartfelt was
this nominated for Oscars yeah I'm
pretty sure it was uh probably a number
of them in fact I wonder what it won
yeah yeah cuz there were some
performances in here oh yeah that were
just unbelievable honestly probably
Octavius Spencer's being my favorite
yeah yeah her eyes man they just like
you can tell exactly what she's thinking
sure sure oh yeah no she's got so much
nuance and expression in every thing she
does the fact that the book came out in
2009 and the movie came out in 2011
that's a very quick turnaround yeah like
the book comes out in 2009 and then
immediately it must have done decently
well because then they must have started
writing the script because they must
have shot it a year later you know like
that is like oh it just feels it feels a
little cash cowy like a little bit and
I'm curious to know again how much of I
mean it says here at least that abene is
based off a person who did work for the
author's family at one point so I I
don't know exactly how much firsthand
experience Katherine Stockett may have
or if she I guess she must have been one
of these kids uh you know raised by her
nanny or whatever um and and yeah it's
one of those things where I'm sure this
does highlight truths and I understand
that there are ways in which like you
know a white person probably had a
better chance of compiling these stories
and getting them published at this
moment in time than a black person would
have so like you mean at the 1960s
moment in time or do you mean in 20 yeah
the 1960s for like where the story is
set in context of the story I kind of
get that it's a person using what you
might call the potential for a platform
you know for the greater good um but
it's making commentary on Al although
ironically it was written by a white
lady in 2009 exact so like and it's you
know authored by white folks as a movie
in 2011 and so like that's the kind of
thing where the disconnect comes around
where yeah it's like I I think it's
probably good for yeah people who
wouldn't otherwise get the perspectives
I don't really know what black audiences
would get out of this as much
necessarily and I just don't have the
perspective to know that so like you can
comment below if you are you know
watching this and you know you're a
black viewer or
whatever um yeah I'm I'm with you it's
interesting because they are they're
just trying to a lot of the movie is
trying to make a commentary on how
poorly the black workers were paid
during this time or how poorly they were
treated during this time and then by
actually putting out this movie and
putting out this novel is it doing
anything to help that problem in which
it's pointing out you know is it doing
anything that we didn't
already know or confront I mean I guess
it's indicative of the you know
resurging
just mindfulness of and discussions
around civil rights as they apply to us
here and now because you know for a lot
of people it's a lot of people I think
we make jokes but there are people who
are like you know yeah the Civil Rights
Movement happened and now we're done
with that and everything's fine and
clearly it's not fine so like there are
reasons to go back and revisit these
stories Octavius Spencer won for this
movie for best supporting actress by the
way okay um additionally Violet Davis
was nominated yeah um Jessica Chastain
was nominated it was nominated for best
picture uh but yeah I would have Octavia
would have probably gotten my vote as
well yeah it's a movie I really enjoyed
in the moment and I appreciated it in
the moment and I thought you know again
it does a decent job at at least you
know spotlighting its black characters
and their story but it is
still yeah I don't know it's it's got
that very crowd-pleasing quality where
it's like the mom comes around and uh
you know H Hilly's mom you know is on
our side is on the audience's side you
know she realizes how terrible her
daughter is and uh you know the book
comes out and and you know the truth
starts to spread and all that stuff and
EM my stone goes off to New York like
there's a lot of stuff that's like
satisfying crowd-pleasing heartstring
tugging about this um but it is a
fantasy I guess to me it does feel more
like a fantasy and not that I even want
to see like I understand too that we
live in a time where people don't just
want to see struggle movies uh and and
struggle porn necessarily or or like
misery porn yeah um but yeah I don't
know it's an interesting it's an
interesting one to take in for sure um I
was looking up right now because I I
remember that uh when Jessica chasty and
Octavia Spencer were doing press about
this I remember reading something about
Jessica Chastain having to fight for
octavus Spencer to get paid more because
they weren't which is like Again part of
which is yeah is like the irony which is
so wacky and strange like yeah I'm just
looking right now cuz I remember hearing
that I looked up this variety thing CH
te promised they were going to be tied
together asking for the same pay and
receiving the same amount for the film
um yeah and I mean like that's good of
Jessica Chastain uh they should have
been she should it shouldn't have had to
have happened in the first place yeah
and there's a lot of that stuff kind of
in the air of this to me
yeah um but a well done movie glad we
watched it it's referenced all the F and
time and like just couldn't have better
caliber actors in it it's really well
made like yeah it's got really good
acting it's got great production values
like you really feel the the place I
think it could have maybe gone a
little I don't know I it might have gone
a little bit harder with a couple of its
actual historical touchstones I mean we
get a little bit of um the me Evers
destination and we get a little bit of
JFK but there's not as much of like
those historical milestones in your face
which I could see some people
appreciating I could see maybe tempering
this a little bit better as a piece of
historical fiction because when it ended
I did have this question of I'm sure a
lot of these experiences are real I'm
sure a lot of experiences are even more
harsh than the ones depicted here I'm
sure this is only scratching the surface
of reality um but I can't tell what
degree of fantasy we're in yeah I know
what youan history yeah but the thing
that felt like the most um out of place
in this movie that was probably my
favorite thing they did was having
Octavia Spencer poop in the pie because
that just that is one of those things
it's like iconic it's like I you know
you're just rooting for that so hard and
as you can tell what's happening and she
says eat my sh and you know like she's
taking the bite and you just know what's
happening whether that's not based on
anything or based on something I was
like get them that's like my favorite
yeah and that's that's a very
crowd-pleasing moment and and I mean I'm
sure it must have happened somewhere at
some point I mean that's that is one of
those things where I'm
like is this appropriate for the story
that we're telling I guess it kind of is
I don't know you know yeah well only
because of all the toilet stuff and it's
like that wasn't yeah I like that I mean
she had a h had it coming for sure he
had it coming all along certainly except
we're not watching Chicago right now
okay those are my thoughts on the help
are those your thoughts on the help I
think so I I I hope we did a decent job
of you know articulating me and you the
two Whitey star that's right well you
know yeah well I'd love to hear what you
guys think please give us help by
leaving a comment let us know if we
missed something if we got it right if
we got it wrong if you guys like this
didn't like this anywhere in between uh
I read all of them I love what people
have to say and this is definitely a
movie the the funny part about reviewing
a movie like this is this is a movie
that I want like other people's feedback
about more so than to like extol my own
you know completely I'm with you so let
us know what you think and we'll see
next time thanks for you ja
bye go pick a name John oh golly let's
do Tyler heg Tyler heg you're never GNA
believe this my friend so I'm gonna give
you a genuine shout out because I got
really sick over Christmas uh the day
before Christmas Eve fell ill traveling
from the south trying to make it to the
Western
lands that's right making a reference to
Red Dead Redemption people because I was
like you know what I didn't even finish
this game I should start this up and uh
I I don't want to be here right now I
just want to keep playing the game oh I
feel like before when I was playing it I
was in a rush cuz it was like there was
the hype you got to beat it you got to
complete Del it and now I can just like
settle in and take it in and I'm like oh
god I've been missing out on this and it
was the reason you got me the PS4 to
begin with and I when I was really
really sick I was for some reason I was
just like craving playing Red Dead feel
like picking it up warm yourself up and
you know what man it is an awesome
awesome game I don't know if you know
this but it's a great game and I just
want to say thank you man because as
I've been recovering this game is come
in handy to help him pass the time yeah
you might still hear my voice I'm still
a little bit under the weather but man
um the last thing I want to do is be
here on a camera talking to you I just
want to be looking at a television with
a controller because of you isn't that
ironic the irony here that I don't want
to give quality time with you but I want
to do something in the name of
you in the name of heg that is my life
anyway Tyler hope you a great Christmas
I hope Santa or the Hanukkah bear
delivered something to you you know you
know love the Hanukkah bear my favorite
holiday mascot oh my God yeah he's
always just going through your trash and
giving leing leaving presents for you in
trash that's right Hanukkah bear looks
more like a raccoon but you know Santa
goes to the chimney Hanukkah bear goes
to the trash yeah totally no stone left
UNT these holiday season learn a thing
or two John if you B brought bother a br
your you I know it's all Jesus to me
anyway Tyler thank you for being you my
friend I love you and I hope you never
unpledge because I can constantly give
you updates on my progress with finally
playing Red Dead Redemption 2 where I'm
at you every month from now on I'm just
going to give you an update on where I'm
at in the game good um because I one day
one I beat 1% oh sick day two I beat
2% day three got to chapter 2 did
3% and I realized if I just did this for
100 days you beat the game dude it's
perfect mathematically sound all right
so goodbye goals hello Red Dead let's
get to it guys thanks
[Music]
Tyler